bonjour José Cachin je me présente je
suis maire adjoint délégué à la culture
et la vénemciel à la à montineî
Bretonneux et si je suis devant vous
c'est simplement pour vous donner trois
bonnes raisons d'aller assister au
concert de Ben
[Musique]
lonclou la première raison c'est que
nous avons très peu de chanteur de souou
en France et indéiablement ben Loncle
souou fait partie des meilleurs la
seconde raison c'est que il viendra dans
le cadre de son concert nous présenter
son dernier album et c'est véritablement
l'album de la maturité et enfin Ben
L'Oncle souou c'est l'assurance de
passer une soirée rassurante apaisée
spirituelle et dansante et ça on en a
bien besoin en ce
moment
[Musique]
je viens donc de vous donner trois
bonnes raisons d'aller voir le concert
de Ben L'Oncle souou si vous êtes
intéressé et si vous souhaitez partager
ce moment avec nous c'est un concert qui
se déroulera à la ferme du Mané le 25
novembre à
20h30